now this war is already taking a
devastating toll on ukrainians just 48
hours ago they could not have imagined
what they are now forced to endure holly
williams is in kharkiv the country's
second largest city where the mayor is
telling citizens to seek shelter it is
the subject of a fierce fight between
russian forces and ukrainians trying to
defend it holly good morning
good morning when vladimir putin
launched this invasion he claimed it was
to stop genocide against people in
ukraine's breakaway regions but there is
no evidence of genocide he also said
that russia wanted to rid ukraine of
nazis a strange claim when the ukrainian
president is jewish the reality as we've
witnessed is a war that has shattered
the lives of ordinary ukrainians
a russian fighter jet terrifying a young
child in a video shared by a ukrainian
official
russia claims it isn't targeting
civilians but in the town of chuhuev
ukraine says the russians bombed this
apartment building killing a teenage boy
and injuring 15 residents
my house is completely destroyed said
olenna carrillo i must have a guardian
angel to still be alive
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
accused russia last night of aiming at
civilians he says he and his young
family are the top targets
in the city of kharkiv just 20 miles
from the russian border the outskirts
have been pummeled leaving 23 civilians
dead according to ukraine but russia is
also taking losses we believe this
soldier was killed by ukrainian forces
on the edge of harkev other russian
troops have been reported as captured
look at this we found harkev's subway
system crowded with people taking cover
from russian missile and airstrikes
the trains have stopped this city is in
the firing line as the russians advance
into the heart of ukraine so this is
your mum and dad like many other
ukrainians
mourinho told us her country is being
held hostage to vladimir putin's dream
of recreating the soviet empire we are
independent and we will stay independent
in the city of mariopol many spent the
night in basements and bomb shelters
i woke up because of the big boom said
this little girl i understood it was the
war
ukraine's foreign minister said quote
putin is plunging europe into its
darkest times since 1939. any government
hoping to sit this out is naive don't
repeat the mistakes of the past adriana
holly williams in eastern ukraine thank
you those images of children
seeing this war up close is just so
chilling